hi everyone
this is professor m science and today i
want to discuss tensor product spaces
this is another one of our videos on
rigorous quantum mechanics
in introductory quantum mechanical
courses we typically concentrate in
simple systems with one degree of
freedom
this is in order to simplify the maths
what this means in practice is that we
have a single particle moving in one
dimension
but of course we want to be able to
describe more interesting problems that
require three dimensions
and more than one particle this is
precisely where tensor product state
spaces come in
they are state spaces that allow us to
describe these more interesting problems
by using the simpler
state spaces as building blocks as an
example
consider a first particle described in a
state space with the associated bases
operators and so on
then imagine a second particle with the
dissociated mathematical construction
now imagine that our system has both
particles in it
in this case how is the state space of
the combined system
related to the individual state spaces
of the two individual particles
the answer relies on a mathematical
formalism known as the tensor product of
vector spaces and this is what we'll
cover today
so let's go we write the tensor product
space v
of the two spaces v1 and v2 like this
where we use this symbol here to
represent a tensor product
the state space v is a tensor product
space if for every pair of states psi
in v1 and phi and v2 there is a
corresponding state in v
which we denote by the tensor product of
psi 1 with phi 2.
in this expression we're labeling each
cad with the sub index
that indicates to which of the original
state spaces the cat belongs to
in this notation the order in which the
terms are written in a the tensorflow
doesn't really
matter because the sub-index already
identifies which state space they belong
to
with this notation then we say that v is
a tensor product space
if it obeys the following properties the
first
is that the tensor product of two
vectors needs to be linear with respect
to scalar multiplication
what this means is that when we multiply
a times the tensor product of
psi with phi this is equal to the tensor
product of
a psi with phi which is also equal to
the tensor product of
psi with a phi and in all these
expressions a is a scalar
the second property is that it is
distributive with respect to vector
addition
what this means is that the tensor
product between psi one plus psi two
with phi is equal to the tensor product
of psi 1 with phi
plus the tensor product of psi2 with phi
we of course have a similar expression
when the addition is between states in
v2 like this
in this notation note that the sub
sub-index outside the ket
is telling us to which of the original
state spaces the cat belongs to just
like above
and the sub-index of the label of the
cat allows us to identify the specific
ket
you should make sure that you understand
the role of each sub-index
because moving on it is very important
to be able to confidently manipulate
expressions in tensor product state
spaces
now that we have defined the tensor
product space we need to understand how
to use it
let's start with basis states we
consider a basis u of state space v1
that has dimension
n1 and the basis v of state space v2
that has dimension n2 it then follows
that the set of states formed by the
tensor products of u
and v basis states form a basis in the
tensor product state space
v if we count all possible combinations
of u and v basis states
we see that the dimension of v is n1
times n2
again note that these sub-indices here
are telling us to which of the two
original state spaces the cats belong to
and the subpoenas here allow us to
distinguish individual cats within a
given state space
to see how we can use the base's state
let's consider general state psi
phi in v the state psi which lives in v1
can be expanded in the u basis like this
the state phi which lives in v2 can be
expanded in a v basis like this
if we then build the tensor product
between psi and phi
we can substitute in the corresponding
expansions to obtain this expression
here
if we use linearity with respect to
scalar multiplication we can move the
sums and expansion coefficients to the
beginning
and we obtain this expression here
so what is this telling us the expansion
coefficients of a tensor product state
are obtained by multiplying the
components
of the two states in the tensor product
what this also means though is that in a
sense these states are trivial
all we need to describe this state in
the tensor product space v is to
actually describe them in the smaller
spaces v1 and v2
and then that fully specifies the
combined state
although this result is rather important
quantum mechanics is much more
interesting than this
to see why consider another ket chi in v
we can always write chi as equal to the
sum over i j of some expansion
coefficients a i j
and the basis states of v which are
given by the tensor product of the basis
states in v1 and v2
now let's ask the question can we always
write this chi
as being built by two states that were
originally only specified in v1 and v2
to be able to do that we should be able
to write a ij as equal to ci times dj
but is this always possible
this is where quantum mechanics gets
exciting because the answer in fact
is no to understand why it's actually
enough to consider a counter-example
imagine that v1 and v2 are both
two-dimensional state spaces
what that means is that then v is a
four-dimensional state space
a general state psi in v1 is given by
these two terms
the general state phi in v2 is given by
these two terms
and the general state chi in v is given
by these four terms
now what does the state in v built from
psi and phi
look like as we just saw it is given by
these four terms
so the question becomes can we find c1
and c2
and d1 and d2 such that c1 d1 is equal
to
a11 c1 d2 is equal to a12
c2 d1 is equal to a21 and c2 d2
is equal to a22 we can rewrite these as
a set of equations
a11 equals c1 d1 a1 to equal c1 d2 and
so on
and now the question becomes where it is
possible to solve this set of equations
simultaneously
here is a very simple counter example
consider a chi given by this expression
here we have a one one equal to one over
square root of two
a one two equal to zero a to one also
equal to zero
and a two two equal to minus one over
square root of 2.
if we now look at this equation then the
second relation here
implies that c1 is equal to 0 or d2 is
equal to 0.
in turn this would imply that either a11
is 0 because it's proportional to c1
or a22 is zero because it is
proportional to d2
but if we check state chi we see that
a11 and a22
are not zero so in fact there is no
possible solution to this set of
equations for this state chi
even this very simple state is an
example of a state in v
that cannot be written as a combination
of two states coming from v1
and v2 states like these are called
entangled states and they play a major
role in many of the most exotic
properties of quantum mechanics
in fact schroedinger who is the person
who coined the term entangled states
described them as not one but rather the
characteristic trait of quantum
mechanics
so you can imagine the important scope
of this result
but before we get too excited about
entangled states we should go back to
the topic of this video which is the
mathematical formalism
behind tensor product state spaces if
you want to learn more about entangled
states check out the videos in the
description
the next quantity i want to look at is
the scalar product between two tensor
product states
let's consider two cats psi and psi
prime in v1
and two cats phi and phi prime in v2
let's also build the tensor product
states between psi and phi
and between psi prime and phi prime both
of which belong to v
we then write the scalar product between
the tensor product states like this
and we define it as equal to the scalar
product between psi and psi prime in v1
multiplied by the scalar product between
phi and phi prime in v2
so what this means is that the scalar
product is pretty straightforward all we
need to do is to group the states
according to which state space they
belong to
to see an example of how this works
let's consider basis states
we built an orthonormal basis u in v1
and another orthonormal base is v
in v2 is the basis uv in the tensor
product state space v
then also orthonormal if we calculate
the scalar product
then we obtain a scalar product between
the use states multiplied by the scalar
product between the v
states and as these are individually
orthonormal
then we obtain this what this means is
that the basis of the tensor product
state space
is also orthonormal
now that we know how cats from two
different state spaces combine in the
tensor product space
a natural question is to ask what
happens to operators
let's start with an operator a1 that
acts on v1
and the second operator b2 that acts on
v2
we define the tensor product between a1
and b2
by its action on states in the tensor
product space
this gives us the tensor product between
a1 psi and b2
phi so what does this mean in the tensor
product the a1 operator acts on the part
of the state associated with v1
and the b2 operator acts on the part of
the state associated with v2
if we remember the discussion on
entangled state we actually know that
not all the states in v can be written
as tensor products of states in v1 and
v2
so we also need to understand how the
tensor product between operators
acts on the most general states that we
can write down in v
to see this consider general ket chi
written in the uv basis
and as we have seen it may or may not be
given as the tensor product of two
states from v1 and v2
we now consider the action of the tensor
product on chi
we start by writing out chi in the uv
basis
then because we're working with linear
operators we can move the operator
inside the sum and looking at how the
tensor product of operators acts up here
we can write this as the sum over i j of
the expansion coefficients a i j
and then the tensor product between a1u
and b2v
and in this way we can also build the
action of the tensor product a1 b2 on
general cats in v
moving on a very common family of
operators that we encounter when we work
with tensor product spaces are operators
that only act on one of the individual
spaces making up
the full state space for example
consider
a1 acting on v1 how does a1 now act in
the tensor product space v
from the discussion we just had we can
write it as a tensor product of a1
with the identity operator in v2
indeed acting with this operator on a
tensor product basis state
then gives us the action of a1 on the
part of the state in v1 and the action
of the identity
on the part of the state in v2 this
simply gives this final expression in
which the part of the state in v2 is
left untouched
of course we can do the same with an
operator b2 that originally acts on v2
and then we promote it to this when it
acts on v
the final thing i want to discuss before
wrapping up are the different types of
notation that are used for tensor
product spaces in physics
let's start with the state which is the
tensor product between psi 1 and phi 2.
this is many times simplified to this
where the tensor product symbol is
simply omitted
another big simplification that is made
very often is to emit the sub-indices
that indicate in which of the original
state spaces the cats belong to
in this case it is understood that the
order in which you write the cats
reflects which state space they come
from
yet another simplification is to write
it like this and again in this case the
order becomes very important and we
understand
that the first entry is associated with
state space v1 and the second entry is
associated with state space v2
to give you an example we can see the
three state spaces those associated with
the
x y and z
spatial dimensions we then build the
tensor product space v
as this tensor product keds in v are
written like this
however they are very often written like
this
or this or this
or even this whenever you see
any of these other forms you need to
remember that this cat is really the
result of a tensor product
so what about operators we typically
write the tensor
product between a1 and b2 as simply a1
b2
in this language the tensor product
between a1 and the identity in v2
can be written like this and this in
turn is often written like this
in this last expression we have lost all
reference to the fact that a1 really
acts on the tensor product space v
but it should always be clear from the
context which state space an operator
like a1
acts on as an example consider two free
particles moving in one dimension
their hamiltonian which is the operator
associated with the energy
is given by the sum of the individual
kinetic energies
in reality you will most often see it
written like this but you need to
remember
what this really means we have learned
that we can use
tensor product state spaces to study
systems that have more than one degree
of freedom
as you can imagine tensor product state
spaces appear all the time
in quantum mechanics and examples
include particles in three dimensions
particles that have
orbital and spin degrees of freedom or
systems that have more than one particle
as an example to see tensor product
state spaces in action check out the
videos on systems of identical quantum
particles
if you liked the video or you would like
send me suggestions for future videos
please subscribe